it's Hell On Earth as hurricane Ian
slams into Florida the evidence of
climate change is indisputable scores of
fires are burning out of control across
Australia the world is already more than
one degree hotter than it was in the
19th century and the temperature is
rising
catastrophic flooding in Pakistan has
killed more than one thousand people
there are growing fears world leaders
are not moving fast enough to save the
planet from a climate crisis
there's an increased frustration really
with the political process in a sense
that this was stalled some are taking
matters into their own hands by suing
governments and fossil fuel companies
for damage caused by climate change
responsibilities
climate activists are waking up to the
power of the law as a tool to drive
change
some of these cases are David and
Goliath litigation pitting some of the
poorest countries and communities
against the world's most powerful
companies all of this area here is all
gone
the fate of the planet at stake could
taking big emitters to court help
finally solve the climate crisis
[Music]
Saul is a farmer and Mountain guide
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Nosotros
s
is
melting Glaciers are a particular
concern to the people of Juarez as the
town sits below Lake parkacocha which is
fed by melt water from the glaciers
above
climate change means these Glaciers are
melting faster than ever and the lake is
growing as a result
bases
[Music]
there is now a very real fear and
Avalanche could trigger a catastrophic
flood from the lake
it wouldn't be the first time this has
happened
when the leg bursts its banks in 1941
it's estimated up to 4 000 people were
killed if it was to happen today it
would be much worse with up to 50 000
lives at risk
foreign
has been campaigning for better flood
defenses for years
claiming the existing siphons
controlling the level of the lake on up
to the job
but so far no one has been willing to
[ __ ] the bill
making changes like improving flood
defenses to cope with the effects of
climate change is known as climate
adaptation it covers everything from
developing heat resistant crops to
building sea walls but it's massively
underfunded all over the world not just
in Peru
if you want to know more about
adaptation and how small Investments
could dramatically reduce the
High climate change then check out our
special report by clicking the link
in 19 and 2020
[Music]
was spent on climate adaptation far
below projections for what's needed and
much less than the 571 billion dollars
spent on mitigation doing things like
replacing fossil fuels with green energy
to cut emissions but there are hopes
this could change
one reason for which adaptation has been
neglected financially perhaps is that
originally it was seen as a poor country
issue we are now seeing annually very
real and very visceral consequences of
climate change fires in California fires
in Australia floods droughts in Europe
This notion that adaptation is just a
poor country issue is very much feeding
as we see these impacts being felt
increasingly and annually in the West
attitudes towards the need for climate
adaptation aren't changing fast enough
in a bid to force the issue he's taken
another route
Saul is suing European energy giant rwe
which is located Halfway Around the
World in Germany to pay for better flood
defenses
it's a groundbreaking case
it's really putting these principles of
transnational climate Justice before the
courts for the first time singling out
one Energy company on the other side of
the globe might seem strange but the
case is based upon advances in climate
science
that allow researchers to estimate how
much carbon individual companies have
omitted since the Industrial Revolution
began
that creates a sort of possibility of
accountability that is being tested in
the courts and that I think we will
probably be seeing a lot more of
This research known as the carbon major
study suggests that German energy giant
rwe is responsible for 0.47 of global
emissions up to 2010. based on this
calculation Saul with the support of a
German NGO is asking rwe to pay 0.47 of
the cost of Shoring up the leg
tempo
0.47 of the cost of the repairs would be
17 000 Euros peanuts to a major energy
firm like rwe whose annual revenue in
2021 was 24.8 billion euros
but this case is about much more than
funds
it's about setting a president
a win in and of itself would be huge and
from speaking to the lawyers involved
Saul's lawyers it also wouldn't just be
a one-off it's very clear that they
would see a win as just the first step
in a whole Suite of suits against carbon
Majors
it's complicated though
rwe points out its emissions were and
are legal and in today's society few
people can claim they don't contribute
to global warming
I went to Peru to meet Saul and I took a
plane to do this I admitted carbon
dioxide the whole complexity of climate
change is that our individual emissions
are all contributing to this problem and
they are all causing damages to people
all around the world
[Music]
owe told economist
it has never been the position of rwe in
this case that climate change does not
exist this case is about whether or not
Mr yuya's very specific allegations
whereby rwe through its historic
emissions is responsible for 0.47 of the
alleged risk for his house can be proven
by The Clement
and as to why rwe does not pay Mr
Luciano yuya the estimated 17 000 Euros
we are not liable and the claim does not
comply with German civil law
[Music]
's case is just part of a deluge of
climate litigation around the world
in the past 10 years the number of
climate-related cases has almost tripled
from 83 in 2011 to 227 in 2021 the vast
majority of these have been in America
here most of the cases against fossil
fuel companies deal with adaptation for
example several coastal cities including
Oakland and San Francisco are suing for
billions of dollars worth of flood
defenses they say they need to cope with
climate change
many of these cases are stuck bouncing
between federal and state courts with
lawyers arguing about where and how they
should be decided or if they even belong
in court at all
corporate lawyers have argued that if
you make it harder and more expensive to
exploit a certain resource the end
result might be just to push that
towards a less regulated country or
company and also if you pursue this
Avenue of seeking climate action through
the courts you end up with a sort of
piecemeal solution to climate change
while there may be legal gridlock in
America climate lawyers have recently
enjoyed an unusual win on the other side
of the world in the tourist straight
Islands this archipelago of the
northmost tip of Australia has been home
to Torres Strait Islander peoples for
Millennia my name is I'm sixth
generation native bloodline from the
tribe of massig Island Central Torres
Strait but here as in Peru climate
change threatens the islander's future
every year approximately one meter of
land is eroded in March 2019 a cyclone
resulted in the loss of three meters of
Shoreline
it's scary because even now as we speak
I think we have to move it back because
it's um
wipe it's getting all the ground is
getting washed away as we speak
rising sea levels mean the islands are
disappearing before their eyes
as storms and erosion destroy homes
livelihoods
and Boreal sites all of her remains was
all laying everywhere
the kids thought they were picking up a
shell when they dug her up that was the
old lady head skull
my grandparents used to have their
Gardens they used to plant sweet
potatoes
cassavas sugar cane you can't plant
anything now
[Music]
the Islanders refused to sit and watch
their homes being destroyed
so they made a historic complaint to the
UN
accusing Australia of violating their
human rights because it had failed to
cut emissions or fund Coastal defenses
and they won in September 2022 Australia
was ordered to pay them compensation and
do whatever was needed to protect their
way of life
I was shocked at first
um at trees of joy and I just gave a big
scream out in the middle of the village
we won our case
the committee was really clear that
climate change is a human rights problem
and that states must protect people from
climate change
it's the beginning
and all the other low-lying Islands
throughout the Pacific and around the
world who was suffering
um
from climate change
they you know it'll open the doors for
them as well
it's not just indigenous people it's
anyone who's living in a vulnerable
location
all states need to look at their
adaptation policies and plans because
they may have to compensate people
Australia has six months to respond with
an action plan
the government seems sympathetic so the
Torres Strait Islanders are hopeful for
Meaningful investment but as the ruling
was issued by the UN human rights
committee not a national court it's not
legally binding
I don't think the courts are just about
winning and losing I think it's about
the big picture of the arguments that
are being made
the courts could exert pressure on
governments they could exert pressures
on companies to address the things that
they haven't been doing fast enough
[Music]
is still waiting for the flood defenses
a huge milestone in this case came in
May 2022 when the German Court including
the case judge visited Juarez to assess
the damage to the lake
foreign
[Music]
's hope is his fight will move the
needle on the climate change debate
before it's too late I'm Catherine
Parikh and I'm the environment editor
for The Economist if you're interested
in learning more about climate
litigation please click on the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe